[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 12 janvier bienvenue dans
le journal de la rédaction de tv 60,18
c'est le tour de l'actualité locale en
quelques minutes voici les titres de
cette édition en janvier c'est le mois
sans alcool le dry january invite à
faire une pause et à s'interroger sur sa
consommation
une opération après une année
particulière où 10% des français avouent
que leur consommation a augmenté pendant
le confinement on en parle avec nos
invités de l'association addiction
france touche pas ma salle le nom de
cette opération les gérants des salles
de sport se sont retrouvés aujourd'hui à
paris pour une mobilisation fermé depuis
plusieurs semaines ces lieux ne
rouvriront pas avant la mi février au
moins de quoi susciter l'inquiétude dans
le secteur exemple à montigny le
bretonneux
et puis pas de sport en salle mais du
sport en plein air tout de même des
clubs de football et de rugby amateur
ont été autorisés à reprendre les
entraînements
pas de match pour autant mais une
pratique sans contact reportage à jouy
en josas où les licenciés se
retrouvaient pour la première fois le
clip fantôme
[Musique]
après les fêtes il est encore temps de
faire recycler votre sapin à suivre
également dans ce journal cette idée
insolite développé par l'agglomération
versailles grand parc le ramassage de
sapins en calèche c'est tout à l'heure
cette information de nos confrères du
point qui est paru aujourd'hui avec
cette nouvelle interpellation dans le
cadre de l' enquête sur l'assassinât de
sagnol pâtit elles ont été opérés
aujourd'hui par la sous direction
antiterroriste et la direction générale
de la sécurité intérieure dans plusieurs
villes de france ces individus font
partie de l'entourage du terroriste de
18 ans qui avait décapité le professeur
d'histoire géographie
c'était le 16 octobre dernier à conflans
sainte honorine ils ont été en contact
avec lui via les réseaux sociaux dans
cette affaire 14 personnes ont déjà été
mises en examen 6 au moins sont toujours
détenus à ce jour
avant de parler du mois sans alcool je
vous le disais dans les titres l'autre
information du jour c'est cette
mobilisation à paris des gérants des
salles de sport elle devait rouvrir
normalement le 20 janvier prochain mais
verront encore leurs portes closes pour
bon nombre de semaines en raison du
contexte sanitaire les professionnels du
secteur sont en colère et ne souhaitent
pas attendre davantage lé précision dans
ce reportage de célia gars de 100 go et
sam le sade dans cette salle de sport à
montigny le bretonneux les machines de
musculation sont à l'arrêt une situation
qui agace le directeur c'est bien de
dire je comprends la colère mais ça fait
en deux ans trois ans ça fait un peu
beaucoup de jeu comprend oui oui je
comprends mais bon surtout je fais rien
je comprends donc c'est beaucoup de mots
c'est beaucoup de sémantique beaucoup de
sophismes j'ai envie de dire aujourd'hui
on aimerait avoir des actes qu'ils
comprennent qu'ils nous montrent
vraiment qu'ils pensent à notre
situation c'est pour cela qu'un
rassemblement devant l'assemblée
nationale a été organisée ce mardi 12
janvier après midi par le collectif
touche pas à ma salle pour protester
contre la fermeture des salles de sport
pour ce directeur il s'agit en plus d'un
véritable paradoxe
le sport ça va être pas mal à lutter
contre les problèmes de santé ça
renforce le système immunitaire sa lutte
contre le diabète de type 2 l'obésité
cette salle d'escaladé à montigny le
bretonneux est fermée elle aussi au
public depuis huit mois
son dirigeant attend davantage d aide en
attendant vu qu'ils ont pris la décision
de nous fermer c'est que vous avez tout
simplement parce que là on entend parler
des aides et des milliards qui sont
débloqués pour l'instant on n'en voit
pas grand chose tout ce qu'on voit c'est
un fonds de solidarité qui va monter à
20% du chiffre d'affaires ce qui couvre
même pas les loyers une période d'autant
plus difficile pour ces établissements
qui sont prêts à rouvrir avec des
mesures strictes on avait imposé le port
du masque pour la lah pour la pratique
de la discipline
on avait du gel hydroalcoolique par tous
les gens ici dans des salles d'aude
escalade se désinfecter mais on continue
et malgré ça derrière on our ferme 1 1
on le dise pas qu'on lit mal c'est qu'on
a l'impression qu'on nous prend pour des
imbéciles
ces deux salles de sport accueille quand
même des personnes munies d'une
ordonnance et les professionnels du
sport grâce au décret qui le permettent
mais cela ne suffira pas pour couvrir
tous leurs frais on connaissait en
novembre le mois sans tabac mais depuis
deux ans dorénavant c'est un mois sans
alcool qui est proposée par plusieurs
associations en janvier on en parle dans
ce journal avec mélanie poker bonsoir ça
de la rédaction de tv 78 en quoi
consiste ce défi ce alors déjà c'est une
campagne de sensibilisation un peu plus
discrète que celle au temps du tabac
pour le moment il n'y a pas de soutien
officiel à des pouvoirs publics
l'initiative vient de nos voisins
britanniques elle a été lancé chez eux
en 2013
et vous l'aurez compris le but est donc
de ne pas boire d'alcool pendant un mois
et l'avantagé c'est que les bénéfices de
ce challenge se font ressentir
rapidement et aussi sur plusieurs mois
et oui alors une étude qui nous vient
elle aussi d'angleterre elle est
réalisée par l'université du sussex
elle nous donne quelques réponses elle
porte sur 800 personnes personnes qui
ont relevé le challenge en janvier 2018
les participants n'ont pas seulement
arrêté sur un mois mais ont diminué leur
consommation
les mois suivants ils boivent moins
régulièrement en semaine que ce soit en
jours mais aussi en quantité de
consommation alors en ce qui concerne le
court terme on peut noter une peau
fraîche et plus belle un meilleur
sommeil un regain d'énergie une
meilleure concentration et une perte de
poids ça ce sont les effets sur la santé
il y a aussi un impact financier puisque
près de 90 % des participants ont confié
avoir fait des économies
merci mélanie pour ces précisions alors
le mois de janvier bien sûr bien entamée
mais pour ceux qui aimeraient se lancer
dans ce défi il existe en un site dryden
harry point fr vous recevrez plusieurs
mails par semaine avec notamment des
astuces pour vous accompagner et on
continue à parler de ce sujet avec mes
deux invités qui sont avec moi en
visioconférence alors il ya eric
lesparre bonsoir soient médecins
hospitaliers médecin addictologue
membres de l'association dé
l'association addiction france pardon
est également à
dès que nous en visioconférence
également c'est johan du top ski bonsoir
ça et vous êtes vous un e animateur
prévention pour cette association alors
l'association addiction france précise
qu'elle agit auprès des populations
surtout les types d'addictions que ce
soit pour l'alcool qui va nous
intéresser aujourd'hui mais aussi sur le
tabac les drogues illicites ou encore
les pratiques de jeu excessif toutes les
addictions donc déjà sur cette opération
le dry january vous avez organisé un
webinaire grand public sur la thématique
quels sont les retours vous avez pu
avoir sur ce webinaire est ce que c'est
une opération qui a intéressé beaucoup
de personnes peut-être young est toxique
qui avait animé ce ce webinaire les
webinaires sert avant tout à promouvoir
le drive initiative des drailles de
parler d'eux en quoi ça consiste
comment est-ce qu'on peut mettre en
place les difficultés qu'on peut
rencontrer donc ce cadet là j'en ai dit
juste avant c'est exactement ce qu'on
vous propose pendant le webinaire et on
permet de proposer des moments d
échanges avec les participants et
participantes pour expliquer si jamais
on l'a déjà mis en place ces lingots
président parce que c'est la deuxième
année qu'on met en face en france les
difficultés qu'on a rencontré comment
est-ce qu'on a commencé à en acheter
pour éviter justement des difficultés
alors c'est une opération forcément
aussi dans un contexte particulier celui
de la crise sanitaire
il ya eu de confinement des couvre-feux
aussi décrété et qui sont toujours en
vigueur aujourd'hui on peut se dire
qu'avec moins de sociabilité qui a eu
moins d'occasions pour boire pourtant
selon l'observatoire français des
drogues et des toxicomanies 10 % des
français ont augmenté leur consommation
pendant lé confinement c'est quelque
chose que vous avez pu observer et ricky
sport tout à fait redemption et je crois
que c'est très bienvenu que ce mois donc
qui nous fait tous réfléchir sur la
consommation permettent au site de
regarder ce qui s'est passé pendant
l'année 2020 avec des personnes qui
commencent à venir consulter parce
qu'ils ont sur consommer pendant cette
période là donc les primes aux
consultants sont
personnes qui disent qu'ils se sont
rendus compte qu'ils de surconsommer il
est évident que l'impact qu'a eu jeudi
recettes ce cette angoisse d'abord de la
la présence de cette pandémie
la précarité pour certains l'isolément
c'est sûr
et le moment où tout d'un coup il était
assez facile de prendre ce produit là
beaucoup plus librement vendu que des
fois des d'autres produits ou les
dealers et autres étaient pas si facile
à récupérer
donc je pense que vraiment il faut
profiter de de l'antenne que vous nous
donnez pour bien dire que le set
cette vague a aussi imprimé une vague
addict aux logiques qui va falloir aussi
qu'on puisse contenir et vous évoquez
que j'étais hospitalier pendant deux
mois on avait plus du tout dans notre
service de possibilité d'accueillir des
personnes venant pour un sevrage quelle
qu'en soit la forme
et quel que soit le produit et que
c'était un énorme souci sociétal qu'il
faut surtout pas reproduire
voilà riches parce que ce qu'il faut
préciser qu'à 0 savoir que des personnes
s'intéressent à leur consommation ou
laurenan consommation sans avoir un
problématique pour autant et je pense
que ça fait avancer le regard des autres
ce qui est important de préciser dans
cette interview on le sait un c'est que
l'alcool est un produit à risque à
partir d'une surconsommation à partir
d'une certaine consommation chaque année
en france on recense environ 41 mille
décès qui sont liés à l'alcool
qu'est ce qui est justement dangereux
dans cette surconsommation d'alcool
quels sont les dangers
les dangers sont immédiats sur des
conduites à risques on voit l'impact que
ça au niveau des urgences et ça ça
touche beaucoup là une population de
jeunes consommateurs il faut savoir
évidemment que c'est un produit
éminemment toxiques qui a des prises de
risque et constante et voyez vous
évoquez les morand en addictologie
tout ce qui a été les morts en 2020 de
cette pandémie pour la france n'est pas
supérieur à ce que chaque année on perd
en terme de mortalité et de morbidité je
dire à côté produit jeudi relier nos
missions d'addiction donc c'est très
important de pouvoir dire effectivement
quand on s'aperçoit qu'on ne devient pas
décideur de la prise de produits il ya
des personnes des consommateurs qui ne
voit pas la fin de la soirée quand ils
commencent à consommer que d'autres
entrent dans un processus de dépendance
physique mais c'est autre chose
et qu'en gros 10 à 15% des utilisateurs
d'alcool risque venir des personnes et
ayant de gros problèmes avant d'en
mourir de façon aiguë est
particulièrement j'insisterai sur les
fonctions cognitives exécutive donc on
risque d'avoir des personnes qui étend
bien jeunes sont déjà très déficitaire
ce chiffre 5 millions de français avoue
boire de l'alcool tous les jours alors
il ya un site le site al commettre point
fr où on peut tester sa consommation à
partir de quel moment johan du top ce
qui est ton dans une situation
d'addiction
c'est pas si facile que ça le déterminer
c'est ça dépend pas forcément de du
rythme à laquelle on auquel on boit de
l'alcool ou la quantité ou ou si c'est
une fois par jour une fois par semaine
on va plutôt parler de l'impact que cela
peut avoir sur la personne n'a autant
sur sa santé que sur sa vie
professionnelle sa vie sociale sa vie
familiale sa vie sentimentale
c'est justement à ça que sert le drive
c'est pas seulement de ne pas boire
d'alcool prenant 1 sont moi mais c'est
surtout de réfléchir à sa consommation à
la place que lui peut avoir dans son
quotidien quand on réfléchit à la place
du produit dans son quotidien
on peut à partir d'un certain moment ne
l'impact que cela peut avoir commencé à
parler d'addiction et de dépendance aux
veaux une dernière question alors si on
est conscient de cette addiction ou que
l'on là où la constate aussi chez chez
un proche
vers qui vers qui se tourner quelles
sont les solutions qui s'offrent à nous
moi je peux vous répondre c'est je crois
que heureusement grâce haussier aux
médias que vous représentez il devient
peut-être plus facile de d'interroger la
question de l'alcoolisation donc en
première ligne les médecins généralistes
doivent pouvoir effectivement être
après quand on est plus dans une notion
de jeu dire de lait coûte parce que dans
cet équilibre qu'il y a de l'histoire de
vie des fois qui est pas facile du tout
de nos consultants gelée que ça passe on
vraiment de la proximité médico psycho
social et ça c'est très important non
payantes je veux dire avait quelque
chose qui est possible après bien
entendu en fonction des typologies ad
d'autres associations que la nôtre nous
en tous les cas il ya un réseau de soins
qui n'est pas assez présent mais qui
quand même et là et d'autre part il ya
aussi des services hospitaliers etc
mais ce qui est important des soins de
suite aussi mais c'est une maladie qui
qui qui englobe tout l'équilibré je dire
familial et amical donc une nouvelle
fois d'en parler le plus vite est
absolument indispensable et tout le
travail de prévention conforme aux
jeunes c'est essentiel c'est une avance
de soins et on fait tout pour
qu'effectivement il n'y ait pas de soins
est bien certaine manière les
initiatives de ce qui se passe
actuellement en terme de prévention
devrait éviter un certain nombre de
rentrer dans le soin et pour plus
d'informations sur cette thématique pour
rejoindre aussi votre association le
site internet de votre association qui
s'affiche actuellement en bas de l'écran
mais merci à eric disparaît et merci en
octobre ce qui d'avoir été avec nous hu
à fond merci avec l'association
addiction france restons dans la
thématique des addictions avec la loi
evin qui fête ses 30 ans en 2021 ce
texte promulgué le 10 janvier 1991 était
destinée à renforcer le dispositif de
lutte contre le tabagisme et l'alcool
elle trente ans après le bilan est
globalement positif comme le souligne
loïc josseran il est président de
l'alliance contre le tabac est
professeur de santé publique à
l'université versailles saint quentin il
a été interrogé par astrid astrid
bergère
[Musique]
il était de lutter contre la
consommation de tabac et la consommation
d'alcool est vraiment de faire baisser
les consommations qui à l'époque était
extrêmement élevé notamment sur le tabac
pouvoir que quand les prémices de la loi
evin et qu'en fait la réflexion était a
été monté autour de ça on avait des
consommations tamanrasset et françaises
qui étaient entre 45 et 50% de
prévalence donc on est des noms des
situations qui était bien différente de
celle qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui pour mémoire d un quart de
la population dans son ensemble
à l'époque on était quasiment dos la loi
evin permis de considérer l'alcool au
tabac comme des produits particuliers
qui avaient une dangerosité et qu'il ne
fallait pas traités comme des produits
de grande consommation habituelle
c'est une grâce à la loi evin que le
black augmenter et que le prix peut
augmenter de façon régulière
il a été sorti d'un dîner privé ce qui
permettait pour l'alcool et la bonne les
faire évoluer plus facilement ses
expériences et un impact économique plus
large les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui on
vient voir que c'est véritablement
l'eldorado publicitaires des industriels
du tabac et de l'alcool
et aujourd'hui c'est un espace n'est pas
réglementée elle est très efficace et
elle va vers la cible prioritaire
l'outil industriel
ils sont justement les les jeunes
dans l'actualité également nous l'avons
appris hier la disparition de raymond
bancaires figurent yvelinoise de la
résistance il s'est éteint le 7 janvier
dernier à 94 ans ses obsèques ont lieu
le 19 janvier à dire au fleix là où il
résidait ancien déporté également
raymond bancaire avait publié en 2018
ses mémoires et venait témoigner
régulièrement dans les écoles du
département pour parler de la seconde
guerre mondiale proposer une solution de
transport complémentaire au réseau de
transport classique dans des zones où
les bus ne passent pas forcément souvent
l'objectif du transport à la demande
déployés par ile-de-france mobilité le
principe l'utilisateur réserve son
voyage en ligne sur une application pour
se rendre ensuite dans une gare ou
d'autres équipements importants et dans
l'agglomération rambouillet territoire
qui proposent ce service
trois nouvelles navettes ont été
déployés depuis le 1er janvier elles
viennent s'ajouter aux trois autres
véhicules déjà existants écouter le
président de la collectivité en
transport à la danse c'est une vraie
réponse 1 sur les zones peu denses qui
sont les nôtres on va pas faire circuler
les mousses toute la journée c'était pas
une réponse adéquate donc on a lancé
cette formule de transport à la demande
juste avant le co lead et qui donne
entièrement satisfaction même si
évidemment pendant confinement ça s'est
ralenti
c'est reparti extrêmement fort à tel
point que en liaison avec l'île de
france mobilité on déploie trois
nouvelles navettes là ce début d'année
2021 pour couvrir une partie des
demandes mais pas que on aura
probablement besoin encore de de
développement dans l'est et dans les
mois qui viennent et les voyages se
réserve ya une application mobile
gratuite transport à la demande
ile-de-france mobilité autres
agglomérations versailles grand parc qui
a lancé une idée insolite et écologique
après les fêtes le ramassage des sapins
de noël en calèche tirée directement par
des chevaux les précisions dans ce
reportage d'eléonore si noter et de
patrick jacques de dixmude pour la
première fois à l'agglomération
versailles grand parc à fait originale
pour le traditionnel ramassage des vieux
sapins de noël
c'est une collecte hippomobile qui a été
mise en place
autrement dit deux chevaux de trait une
calèche et des rippeurs les chevaux
c'est quand même agréable c'est
pédagogique c'est pas le même bruit
effectivement qu'un camion
les enfants les mêmes les gens on voit
déjà qu'il sourit en voyant les chevaux
donc effectivement c'est pas c'est pas
la même approche
et puis puis ça change c'est agréable du
8 au 13 janvier les sapins sont donc
ramassé dans trois communes noisy-le-roi
bailly et rémoulins la tâche a été
confiée à l'entreprise les calèches de
versailles dont l'écurie est composé
d'une vingtaine de chevaux de trait le
fait de les utiliser dans ce cadre là a
un réel intérêt puisqu'on n'est pas
moins rapide qu'un camion en faisant du
porte à porte sur ce type de collecte
donc une efficacité quasi totale par
rapport avec une motorisés et bien sûr a
un impact écologique qui est qui et bien
sûr palpable puisque voilà 100 et on
utilise une énergie propre une énergie
renouvelable qui est l'énergie cheval en
plus du ramassage écologique le
compostage est aussi effectué localement
à la plateforme bio yvelines située à
bailly à noisy le roi
les habitants sont ravis c'est la
première année et j'espère que ça va
continuer on n'a pas du tout l'habitude
de voir des chevaux dans nos rues donc
je suis passé voir j'avais l'information
parce que il y avait eu des flyers dans
les boîtes aux lettres
donc voilà je trouve l'initiative très
sympa l'agglomération versailles grand
parc n'exclut pas de reconduire
l'opération l'année prochaine voire même
de l'étendre à d'autres communes si
elles en font la demande
et puis au début de ce journal nous vous
parlions de la pratique du sport en
salle qui n'est plus autorisée en ce
moment stoppé par le deuxième
confinement novembre les footballeurs
amateurs ont pu le reprendre le chemin
de l'entraînement
ces dernières semaines les horaires sont
adaptés et le jeu doit s'effectuer sans
contact
exemple dans le club de jouy en josas
avec bixente mayence insisté ban et
patrick jacques de dixmude
il attendait ça avec impatience les
footballeurs peuvent à nouveau fouler
leur pelouse de nombreux clubs amateurs
ont repris les entraînements des
retrouvailles entre coéquipiers après
deux mois d'arrêt le groupe l'ambiance
tout ça ça manque ça manque beaucoup
pas de voir les amis tout est fermé donc
forcément de se retrouver comme ça le
dimanche c'est top ça fait du bien déjà
de retrouver les copains de retrouver
l'esprit d'équipé faire un petit peu
l'activité physique et sportive en
collectivité parce que faire tout seul
pendant confinement s'est pas forcément
très agréable
les horaires ont été adaptés selon les
clubs en raison du couvre-feu pour lui s
jouy en josas
c'est un entraînement le samedi matin et
un autre le dimanche de 14h à 16h au
programme des exercices sans contact on
verra aussi comment comment la situation
sanitaire évolué puisque on peut pas
jouer encore complètement on appellera
au contact par aux oppositions donc
c'est quand même un manque aussi pour
nous le foot permet comme de faire des
exercices sans contact aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup de gamme comme on peut le voir
derrière voilà malgré même si on fait
pas de match à la fin c'est pas grave au
moins on s'est retrouvé en afrique
ballon quoi les clubs avancent malgré
tout l aveugle sans visibilité pour le
reste de l'année on en était à quatre
matchs joués sur huit normalement donc
on a eu quatre matches annulés déjà et
on est une poule de douze donc il faut
au moins onze matches aller pour pour
terminer la phase aller et il ya 22
matchs en tout sur toute la saison et la
saison c'est un mini d'euros
officiellement le 30 juin
donc après on peut plus continuer de
faire la saison s'arrêtera le 30 juin
quoi qu'il arrive
l'équipe espère au moins finir la
première moitié de la saison pour
l'instant de solution semble privilégiée
par la fédération française de football
avancer de manière traditionnelle en
essayant de jouer autant de matches que
possible ou bien scindé les poules en
deux afin d'organiser des plus petits
championnats dans un système de playoffs
et play down
dans un instant sur tv 78 ne manquez pas
le premier numéro de l'année du 7-8
culturelle continue la culture malgré
tout en cette période dans son émission
justin brasier parlera d'une comédie
musicale qui se prépare dans un collège
de saint germain en laye du chaland
chanson lancée par l'association signes
et imagée du prix à clara un concours
d'écriture pour les jeunes c'est à
partir de 18h30
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité demain vous
retrouverez eléonore si nokia la
présentation d'une nouvelle édition soit
on retrouvera nous jeudi sur ce journal
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]